why
isn't objectivism more famous
and i think because it's so challenging
it's
it's not challenging to me right when i
first encountered objectivism
it's like after the first shock and
after the first uh
kind of none of this can be true this is
all bs
and fighting it once i got it
it was easy it was easy it required
years of studying but it was easy in the
sense of yes this makes sense
but it's challenging because it upends
everything
it really says what my mother taught me
is wrong and while my politicians
say left and right is wrong all of them
there's not a single politician on which
i agree with on
almost anything right because on the
fundamentals we disagree
and what my teachers are telling me is
wrong
and what jesus said is wrong and
it's hard but the thing is so you you
talk about politics and all that kind of
stuff
but you know most people don't care the
the more powerful thing about
objectivism is the
practical of my life of
how i revolutionized my life and it that
feels to be like a very
important and appealing you know get
your [ __ ] together kind of
yeah but this is why this is why jordan
peterson is so much more successful than
we are right why is that
make your bed or whatever what's that
make you're better yeah because
his personal responsibility is shallow
it's make your bed stand up straight
it's what my mother told me when i was
growing up there's nothing new about
jordan peterson
he says embrace christianity
christianity's fine
right religion is okay just
do these few things and you'll be fine
and by the way he says
happiness you know you either have it or
you don't you know it's random
you don't actually you can't bring about
your own happiness she's giving people
an easy out
people want easy outs people buy
self-help books
that give them five principles for
living you know shallow
i'm telling them think stand on your own
two feet
be independent don't listen to your
mother
do your own thing but thoughtfully not
based on emotions
so you're responsible not just for a set
of particular
habits and so on you're responsible for
everything
yes and you'll respond here's here's the
big one right
you're responsible for shaping
your own soul
your consciousness you get to decide
what it's going to be like
and the the only tool you have is your
mind your only reason
is is your mind well your emotions play
a tool when they're properly cultivated
they play a role in that
and the tools you have is thinking
experiencing living
coming to the right conclusions you know
listening to great music and
and watching good movies and and and art
is very important in shaping your own
soul
and helping you do this it's got a it's
got a
crucial role in that but it's
work and it's lonely work
because this work you do with yourself
now if you find somebody who you love
who shares these values and you can do
with them that's great but it's mostly
lonely work it's hard it's challenging
it ends your world
the reward is unbelievable but
but even at the think about think about
the enlightenment right
so up until the enlightenment where was
truth truth came from a book
and there were a few people who
understood the book most of us couldn't
read
and they conveyed it to us and they just
told us what to do and in that sense
life's easy it sucks and we die young
and we have nothing
and we don't enjoy it but it's easy
and the enlightenment comes around and
says we've got this tool
it's called reason and it allows us to
discover
truth about the world it's not in a book
it's actually your reason allows you to
discover stuff about the world
and i consider the first really the
first
figure of the enlightenment is newton
not locke right it's a scientist
because he teaches us the laws
of mechanics like how does stuff work
and
people go oh wow this is cool i can use
my mind
i can discover truth isn't that amazing
and everything opens up once you do that
hey if i can discover
if i understand the laws of motion if i
can understand truth in the world
how come i can't decide who i marry i
mean everything was fixed in those days
how come i can't decide what profession
i should be in
right everybody would belong to a guild
how come i can't decide who my political
leader should be
that's so it's all reason it's all once
you understand the efficacy of your own
mind to understand truth to understand
reality discover truth not understand
truth discover it
everything opens up now you can take
responsibility for your own life because
now you have the tool to do it
but we are living in an era where
post-modernism tells us there is no
truth there is no reality and our mind
is useless anyway
critical race theory tells us that
you're determined by your race
and your race shapes everything and your
free will is meaningless and your reason
doesn't matter
because reason is just shaped by your
genes and shaped by your color of your
skin
the it's the most racist theory of all
and you've got
you've got our friend at uc irvine
telling them
oh your senses don't tell you anything
about reality anyway reality is what it
is so
do you know what's the purpose of reason
it's the invent stuff it's to make stuff
up and what use is that it's complete
fantasy
you've basically got every philosophical
intellectual voice in the culture
telling them their reason is impotent
there's like a stephen pinker who tries
and i love
pinka and he's he's really good and i
love his books
but you know he needs to be stronger
about this
and there's a few people on kind of
there's a few people partially in the
intellectual dark web and otherwise who
are big on reason
but not consistent enough and not full
understanding of what it means or what
it implies
and then there's little old me
and it's me against the world in a sense
because i'm not only willing to accept
to to articulate the case for a reason
but then what that implies it implies
freedom it implies capitalism it implies
taking personal responsibility over your
own life
and the other intellectual dark web
people get to reason and
oh politics you you can be whatever no
you can't you can't be a socialist and
for reason
right it doesn't actually those are
incompatible
and you can't be a determinist and for a
reason
reason and determinism don't go together
the whole point of reason
is that it's an achievement it requires
effort and requires engagement it
requires
choice so it is it does feel like a
little ob
because that's that's it i the allies i
have are allies
i have allies among the some
libertarians over economics i have some
allies in the intellectual dark web
maybe over reason
but none of them are allies in the false
sense so my allies are the other
objectivists but we're just they're not
a lot of us
for people listening to this for the
few folks kind of listening to this and
and thinking
about the trajectory of their own life
i guess the takeaway is a reason
is a difficult project but a project
that's
worthy of taking on yeah difficulties
i don't know if difficult is the right
word because difficult sounds like it's
you know i have to push this boulder up
a hill it's not difficult in that sense
it's difficult in the sense that it
requires energy and focus it requires
effort
but it's immediately rewarding it's fun
to do
and it's rewards uh
immediate uh uh pretty quick right it
takes a while to undo all the garbage
that you have
but we all have that i had that took me
years and years and years to get rid of
certain concepts and certain emotions
that i had that didn't make any sense
but it takes a long time to fully
integrate that
so i i don't want it to sound like it's
a
burden like it's hard in that sense it
does require focus and energy
and i don't want to sound like a dr
spock
i don't want to and i don't think i do
because i'm pretty passionate guy
but i don't want it to appeal like oh
just forget about emotions
emotions how you experience the world
you want to have strong emotions
you want to live you want to experience
life
strongly and passionately you just
need to know that emotions are not
cognition
it's another realm it's like don't mix
the realms
think about outcomes and then experience
them and sometimes your emotions won't
coincide with what you think
should be and that means there's no more
integration to be done
you